- [Narrator] Transportation,
food, housing.
These are some of the biggest categories
in the consumer price index market basket.
One of the measures
used to track inflation.
And here's how they're weighted.
You can see housing or
what the BLS calls shelter
makes up about a third
of the market basket
which means it can be a big factor
in either driving or tempering inflation.
- I think that shelter inflation
is gonna remain high for some time.
You know we're looking for it to come down
but it's not exactly clear
when that will happen.
- [Narrator] But it's also
one of the hardest numbers
to measure.
And as you can see
here, it can keep rising
even when inflation in other
items begins to slow down.
- That can make things complicated
for the Fed and policy makers
if they're trying to push inflation down
as they are right now.
- [Narrator] Here's why housing
is one of the trickiest items
in the basket to measure
and why it holds so much
weight in the overall index.
When the BLS measures for shelter
it's measuring for the service
that a housing unit provides its occupants
or more simply the cost
or value of your home.
- You think of how much
money you spend every month.
A big chunk of that goes to
your rent or your mortgage
and that's the case for
households across the country.
So if it's a big part
of your monthly spending
it's gonna be a big part
of the overall inflation calculation.
- [Narrator] The index
includes changes in prices
for four different categories,
but these two are the most important.
Rent and something called
Owner's Equivalent Rent.
Let's look at this one first.
On the surface it's
pretty self-explanatory.
It tracks prices people pay for rent.
While it's less volatile than home prices
measuring for rent poses
some challenges for the BLS
because it's sticky.
That means it changes infrequently
since most prices are locked in place
throughout a lease term.
But that sticky price means
the BLS has to gather data
for it differently than it
does for other categories.
Data for things like
food and transportation
are gathered every month or two
but it's only gathered for rent every six.
Sample areas called panels
report on a staggered schedule.
So one might report prices
in January and July.
While another reports
in February and August.
That means that changes in rent
might not trickle into the BLS data
for months down the line.
- What the BLS is trying to do is
it's trying to capture both the people
who are in the market for a new apartment,
who are signing new leases,
and the people who are
in their existing lease
who are paying the same
price they were paying
the last month.
So the BLS is trying to get a
picture of the overall market,
sort of every renter.
- [Narrator] According to
a study by the Dallas Fed
changes in the rental
market can precede changes
in the shelter index by about a year.
- We have to wait for enough
people to sign new leases
or to renew their leases
for those price increases
to actually show up.
- [Narrator] But this isn't
even the trickiest part.
The other even bigger slice of the index
is called Owner's Equivalent Rent or OER.
This is the price an owner would pay
to rent a comparable home.
The BLS doesn't factor
house prices into the CPI
so they don't show up directly in this.
That's because it considers home ownership
and investment rather than a
consumable good or service,
like food or airplane tickets.
So instead, the BLS assigns
owned homes and equivalent rent
based on the average
rental prices in the area.
It's an estimate.
So rental prices can cause a lag
and OER can be somewhat imprecise
and you can see that that
can make the shelter index
look really different from
what's actually happening
in the housing market.
That can make a difference
in inflation numbers
because as you can see here,
shelter is taking up an increasing
share of the overall CPI.
Here's Douglas Holtz Eakin,
Former Director of the
Congressional Budget Office
on the importance of bringing
shelter inflation down.
- If the Fed wants to hit a 2% target
and shelter inflation is at 6%
everything else has to be zero.
That's not gonna happen.
So the Fed needs to bring
down shelter price inflation
and it will increasingly raise rates
and tighten financial
conditions until it does.
- [Narrator] This pressure
means the shelter index's lag
can make things complicated
for Fed officials.
We're looking to affect overall
inflation month to month.
- The last thing they wanna see right now
is inflation going up.
I mean they've already put in place
a number of rate increases.
They have more plans, so
they're really looking for signs
that inflation is coming down
and this is pushing in
the opposite direction
even if it's, you know
likely to be temporary.
- [Narrator] Fed Governor
Christopher Waller said in October
that while housing inflation should slow,
"Increases in broader interest rates
should help moderate demand
and damp inflation in other
sectors," in the meantime.
Though there isn't a specific date
that the shelter index
could start to cool.
Economists expect it to start to come down
anytime between the end
of the year and mid 2023
but it will keep adding to inflation
even as the housing market settles down.
(soft upbeat music)